and I've been dancing since I was seven
years old working for me represents just
being free and moving my hips and like I
like twerking it's just like natural
Bali has been going on for so many years
it's centuries of years old and it's
very traditional the hardest part about
ballet is definitely the technical parts
of it like staying turned out all the
time and pointing your feet and
straightening your legs and all the
placement and all my time dancing
there's never been much of a mention of
anything with science fellow I think
working is really cool I've never done
it I'm glad to teach them how to I think
I'll go to the club tonight so get into
first position and plie and out to
second and plie and stay there and I've
worked in my own mind I don't remember a
lot of it there's unser Bert working a
just go all the way down right I'm like
falling I don't know if my body can't
work not your whole body it's a lot to
think about
all right Roy who's gonna get down dirty
we're gonna get down to the floor
get in our knees arch into it arch your
back
so everybody drop down and pop your body
at the same time you can do it don't
think I just don't think we are ready to
take it to the obstacle course we're
gonna go across the floor you're gonna
start with your hands behind your head
and you're gonna kick with your right
and then kick with your left and come
down move your hands or your knees and
back it up three times one two three and
then you're gonna drop down to your
knees and go across the floor
one two you guys can do it
I think I'll be incorporating twerking
into my team right it was kind of like a
freedom movement it's so fun I am going
to like play a trick game while I'm in
class now that like every time the
teacher that turns around
how much is twerk I feel like a
superstar guys I've got everybody my
heart's are gonna marry